Can you find the hidden giraffe?
And this cat doesn't need glasses.
It's episode 48 of IMG!
Bobby Neel Adams takes a photo of a person
as a child and then has them replicate the
pose as an adult.
He then rips the photos to fit.
The effect is haunting and cool.
But this is just lonely.
Pareidolia is when you see something of significance,
a face, a pattern, in something random.
But if you put the face there, you're like
gnomers.
Prefer dogs?
Well, Buzzfeed showed off the scariest dog
pictures possible and to alleviate your fear,
here is Maddie the Dog.
On things.
Maddieonthings.com
Name brand arm tattoos are a smart idea and
so is eating healthy.
Wait, whaaat... is this guy so excited about?
Hmmm.
I also don't know what's going on here and
okay, I guess we'll have to remove all the
art inside.
ThumbPress brought us a subway map of rock'n'roll,
which genres and intersections do bands exist
on.
They also showed us how not to be a good parent,
though a leaf blower to the face is pretty
fun.
Thousands of Braille products, many of which
you've never... seen before?
These items cast the shadow of a city and
these glass paper aeroplanes cast a combined
shadow that resembles a city on the bay.
Oh, and these water bottles add definition
and shading to cast the shadow of a man's face.
Photographer Hal takes photographs of couples
shrink-wrapped in plastic.
He must act quickly or they'll suffocate.
Seriously, this is real.
As are these celebrity names.
Jon Stewart's real name is John Leibowitz.
Ralph Lauren's original name was Ralph Lipschitz.
But the craziest of them all?
Michael J. Fox.
His actual, original name, and I'm not kidding,
is Michael A. Fox.
But now, Chevrolet's speedometer designs from
1941 to 2011.
Now where is this guy on TV looking?
Mmmhm.
Well, what about him?
Oh, come on!
TV people even photobomb kids kissing.
See?
Bread shoes.
Remember those scary dogs?
Well, dogs and cats can also be loving companions.
Enjoy.
Now here's a question.
How big is a million dollars?
I mean, what would having a million dollars
look like?
According to this great study, it's only about
5 reams worth of paper.
Heavy, but enough to carry around yourself,
if you used $100 bills.
This, however, is what 206 million dollars
in cash looks like.
About the size of a king mattress.
Painting on brick is one thing, but letting
it drip like rain is another.
Sam3's street art asks the question, "when
you look into the sky, what's looking back
at you?"
Now, if you're afraid of getting caught painting
on buildings, do it like this.
Jim Denevan goes even larger.
By driving around on a dry lake bed, very
very exactly, he manages to carve mathematically
impressive circles into the Nevada landscape.
Large enough to be seen from space, but temporary
enough to be quickly washed away by rain and wind.
MoIllusions had this this week.
A blue shape that seems to tick every time
the gap between the red and blue shapes disappears,
though the blue shape never moves.
It's caused by ambiguous figure-ground segregation.
Eric Tabuchi went on a French-American road
trip, finding stores with American city names
without having to leave France.
Or his own bedroom.
The entire book isn't photographs, it's Google
Street View screenshots he took on his computer.
With the Internet, why go anywhere?
Tabuchi also collected the alphabet from trucks.
Now, planking is too flat.
We want twists and turns.
You know, like Takanori's bonsai trees houses.
Finally, David Aday cuts pictures of people
into fun little shapes and then pins them
to walls to make the person complete again.
Except in a separated kind of way.
Follow us on Facebook and Twitter for more.
And as always,
thanks for watching.